Donald Trump had what we call an upper
morning there's upper Trump and downer
Trump upper Trump is the Trump that
tweets uncontrollably and Trump this
morning tweeting again and again and
again and again everything from
conspiracy theories to disinformation to
wild attacks on people and I want to
remind you that this is not normal and
we have to balance at the David Pakman
show I think everybody has a
responsibility to balance on the one
hand we don't want to publicize what
Trump says on Twitter as reasonable
presidential speech but we also can't
ignore that while other world leaders
and past American presidents have
focused on doing their jobs we now have
a president whose Twitter feed is
indistinguishable from a sort of weird
blend of Alex Jones conspiracy theorist
and Breitbart right-wing propagandists
so let's check it out first talking
about once again the Roger stone trial
and the judge Amy Berman Jackson quoting
from of course Fox & Friends this
morning saying quote judge Jackson now
has a request for a new trial based on
the unambiguous and self outed bias of
the foreperson of the jury who's also a
lawyer by the way um whose as opposed to
who ' yes madam foreperson you're a
lawyer why oh you are as opposed to you
apostrophe re you have a duty and
affirmative obligation to reveal to us
when we selected you the existence of
these tweets in which you were so
harshly negative about the president and
the people who support him don't you
think we wanted to know that before we
put you on this jury pretty obvious he
should get a new trial I think almost
any judge in the country would order a
new trial I'm not so sure about judge
Jackson I don't know
then Trump going into a three tweet
spell including an all caps tweet about
robert muller saying quote these were
molar prosecutors and the whole molar
investigation was illegally set up based
on a phony and now fully discredited
fake dossier capitalizing F and D lying
and forging documents to the FISA Court
and many other things now none of these
things are true none of these things are
true Trump going on to say everything
having to do with this fraudulent
investigation is
idly tainted and in my opinion should be
thrown out even molar statement to
Congress that he did not see me to
become the FBI director again has been
proven false the whole deal was a total
scam if I wasn't president I'd be suing
everyone all over the place and then all
caps but maybe I still will witch-hunt
then briefly drip a sort of dipping into
the crooked DN C stuff which is actually
smart to get some crossover interest
from Bernie supporters tweeting the
crooked DNC is working overtime to take
the Democrat nomination away from Bernie
again watch what happens to the
super-delegates in round two a rigged
convention Trump maybe not wrong about
that one
then going into another three tweets
Creed about the u.s. being difficult to
deal with saying quote the United States
cannot and will not become such a
difficult place to deal with in terms of
foreign countries buying our product
including for the always used national
security excuse that our companies will
be forced to leave in order to remain
competitive we want to sell I have seen
some of the regulations being circulated
including those being contemplated by
Congress and they are ridiculous I want
to make it easy to do business with the
u.s. not difficult everyone in my
administration is being so instructed
with no excuses the United States is
open for business this is not normal but
you've got to hand it to them it said
there's something for everybody sort of
a few hours of craziness on Twitter if
you are most concerned with the DNC
trying to deny Bernie the nomination
Trump is tweeting something for you if
you are one of the folks that was
bamboozled by Trump knowing about trade
and how he would deal with the economy
you have a three tree three tweet screed
that's hard to say that three times fast
a three tweet screed about the economy
and about the US as a place for business
and trade and so on and so forth if you
are still in the Trump is the most
persecuted victim little up all that
stuff then you've got Trump going after
Muller about a witch
and life Aiza this that the other thing
there's something for everybody here and
you've got to zoom out and realize it's
just not normal for a president to be
doing any of this stuff regardless of
what the content here is and it may
rocket him towards re-election that's
the saddest part of the entire thing
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram for more on
this and other stories from today's show
at david pakman show on instagram if you
enjoy shows like shark tank or you're
fascinated by entrepreneurs and how they
become successful I've got something
really cool for you to check out the
YouTube channel we're partnering with
called up flip and you can find it at
david pakman.com slash up flip it's a
new channel they're hitting the ground
running with really excellent content
they're uploading new videos all the
time in each video you meet a different
entrepreneur and take an in-depth look
at how they built their business from
the ground up you can examine the
business up-close learn their strategies
for success see what it's like to live a
day in their shoes as an entrepreneur
myself I find this stuff endlessly
interesting I love learning about how
business owners got to where they are
what motivates them what the turning
points were and everyone who's featured
in up flips videos have their own really
cool insights to share but it's content
that's really easy to appreciate even if
you don't have your own business
every entrepreneur on up flip has their
own story to tell they're all
fascinating check it out if you watch my
show check out up flip this is part of a
partnership we're doing with them
they're friends of ours I think you'll
really enjoy their content it's really a
different it's unique there's something
for everybody check it out subscribe to
their channel at david pakman.com slash
up flip